this is actually a decisive moment for a
lot of women in afghanistan
[Music]
the first day after
the takeover i woke up to the shoutings
and gunfires in our doorstep
and there were thieves who were calling
themselves mujahideen as part of taliban
and they were trying to steal cars and
belongings of people the last few days
they have been quite chaotic and quite
unpredictable for a lot of people
22 year old aisha kuram was in the final
semester of our international relations
degree at kabul university when the
taliban took over the capital city of
afghanistan on august 15th
kuram was an afghan youth representative
to the u.n in 2019.
on sunday
some of the teachers they said goodbyes
to their female students specifically
and then everything happened
it was not clear whether it was for the
taliban banning woman from attending
universities or whether it was for the
separation that might happen between
boys and girls and the universities
there are statements by taliban they
were saying that they will protect and
um they will respect women's rights
within the framework of sharia law
however this is quite vague
at the moment there's a lot of
uncertainties i personally do not know
whether i would be able to go back to
universities
the taliban is now in full control of
the afghan government
afghanistan's former president ashraf
ghani fled the country with his family
to the united arab
people
emirates
trying to make sure that the situation
gets certain and things clear out and
then step outside resume their usual
work but at the moment the lack of order
and the lack of governance and
accountability it's quite difficult for
people to trust and go out especially
for women
despite the confusion many afghans are
still continuing to speak out
right now the young generation is trying
to demonstrate that we are the reality
the new reality of afghanistan that is
connected with the world that progressed
a lot since 2001 and they are trying to
make sure that those progresses that
young generation afghanistan may would
not be reversed and the taliban's regime
kuram remains hopeful but vigilant
she wants to see if the taliban will be
able to peacefully coexist with the new
values afghanistan has seen
this is actually a decisive moment for a
lot of women in afghanistan especially
the young girls who did not experience
taliban's regime in 1990s and
those women who are hoping to continue
their education to continue their
presence and the society we are trying
right now to make sure their voices
aren't heard and that taliban would
accommodate them in any future
government and respect their rights in
freedom
a lot of afghan people they feel this
sense of
abundance i hope that
the world will will not um isolate
afghanistan um and i hope that the
humanitarian situation and crisis that
afghan people are facing at the moment
will be a wake-up call to the world the
younger generation of afghanistan needs
the world um more than ever before
[Music]